son estas sanciones un golpe definitivo
a la economía de moscú
bueno andrés antes que nada muchas
gracias por la invitación un saludo
también a toda la audiencia que está
mirando son un golpe muy importante
efectivamente es un gran golpe a la
economía a la economía rusa se suma a
toda una serie de sanciones que se
vienen dando en los últimos días sobre
todo a partir de la invasión ucraniana
todo lo que había sido por ejemplo la
desconexión del swift entre otras
cuestiones un aislamiento ya casi total
de ese hecho la comunidad internacional
rusia rusia hoy es el país con mayor
sanciones del mundo superando países
como irán o venezuela o incluso corea
del norte para que te des una idea la
importancia del gas y el petróleo ruso a
europa importa el 90 por ciento del gas
que utiliza el 40 por ciento proviene de
rusia y europa también importa el 97% de
los productos derivados del petróleo que
utiliza es un porcentaje importante
también viene viene de rusia eeuu en
cambio no importa
natural ruso por lo cual no lo afecta de
la misma de la misma manera de hecho
eeuu puede llegar a aprovechar esta
situación para exportar gas a europa
porque imagínate que se va a quedar sin
el 40 por ciento del total de sus
importaciones de si las sanciones
continúan por lo menos en el corto
inclusive en el mediano plazo pensando
en el invierno en el invierno que viene
esto por supuesto también está teniendo
consecuencias importantes en la economía
internacional en la suba de precios de
los combustibles el precio del gas de la
energía y en un contexto además que no
hay que perder de vista e inflacionario
eeuu tienen la mayor inflación de los
últimos 40 años por supuesto repercute
en la economía mundial en la economía
global
sin ninguna duda baa sigue repercutiendo
y seguramente se va a acelerar la
inflación también señor fiebre que
cambiamos enfoque porque después de
muchos años a eeuu y el gobierno
venezolano de nicolás maduro volvieron a
reunirse para discutir según la casa
blanca la seguridad energética de la
región escuchemos lo que dijo el
presidente venezolano yo ratifico
como le dije la delegación toda nuestra
voluntad
desde la diplomacia
desde el respeto
y desde la máxima
esperanza de un mundo mejor
y nosotros poder avanzar en una agenda
que permita el bienestar y la paz
ahora le pregunto un eventual
levantamiento de las sanciones a las
petroleras venezolanas sería a través la
solución a la demanda de petróleo y la
subida de los precios tras las acciones
a russián
bueno no sé si la solución definitiva
pero si podría llegar a aliviar un poco
la situación y la importa es la
necesidad de importación de petróleo por
parte sobre todo de europa también e
incluso de los eeuu que nos encontramos
ante una situación que uno no esperaba
hace tan sólo unos meses atrás no donde
veces suele de alguna manera está
regresando de la mano de washington a
dejar de ser o por lo menos empezar a
dejar de ser una especie de paria en la
comunidad internacional a partir de
todas las sanciones que venía a las que
venían siendo sometidos el discurso de
maduro se empezó a cambiar respecto de
los eeuu ya no como un enemigo sino como
un probable ilusión probable socio no
entonces lo que puede tener unas
consecuencias más allá de las
consecuencias económicas que seguramente
van a ser importantes también estarían
atentos a las consecuencias políticas
que como esto va a influir tanto para
américa latina en lo que tiene que ver
con la política y la situación el caso
muy particular queda parado la discusión
del caso venezuela y como esto va a
cambiar la relación con los eeuu